Let’s continue our discussion about the
sense of vision. One of the things that makes
vision such a powerful sensor is that it is
a long-range sensor. It allows us to sense
the world beyond our fingertips. Our fingertips,
our arms only allow us to reach and explore
a relatively small part of the space that
is around us. But sometimes the most important
things that we need to know about are far
beyond the reach of our fingertips; by the
time things are that close it is perhaps too
late, so vision allows us to see for tens
of meters, hundreds of meters, a very great
distance and that is a really big virtue of
the sense of vision.
Another important characteristic of a sense
of vision is that it provides a very rich
amount of information. We know something about
the shape of the object, we know something
about the colour of the object, and that shape
and colour in addition to texture allows us
to classify the object to work out what sort
of thing it is. Is it a thing that we are
interested in? Is it something we want to
run away from? Or we want to move towards?
What sort of object it is, and that is absolutely
critical for many, many applications for people
and also for robots.
Another great advantage of vision is it gives
us information about motion and it tells us
about how things are moving around us, so
we can see an object and we can see it moving.
Is it getting closer to us, is it going further
away? But it also provides a lot of information
about how we are moving, so as we walk through
the world other things appear to move past
us due to our own motion.
The fact that so many animals use vision and
that the sense of vision has evolved independently
multiple times here on planet earth argue,
I think, for the effectiveness of the sense
of vision. For almost all animals we use the
sense of vision for the really important things
in life. We use it to help us find food, we
use it to avoid being eaten by other animals
and we use it to find our mates. So all the
important life functions are mediated through
the sense of vision.
Have a look at these tasks being preformed
by a variety of different animals. Consider
the bee, and a bee is a small animal, with
a very small brain, but it has got two eyes.
Quite complex eyes, very different sorts of
eyes to ours, but it can perform quite complicated
functions. It can fly for a long distance
in order to locate some flowers that other
bees have informed it about. It can land on
a moving flower or it can tell the difference
between a flower and a leaf. So quite complex
functions critical to the life of the bee
and its colony are performed essentially using
vision.
In the middle, we have somebody catching a
ball. They are using their eyes to catch the
ball. They are not using GPS or any other
kind of technological sensor. This person
has got their eyes on the ball and that is
a very well-known expression. Watching the
ball as it moves through the air and they
have got some sort of mental model about how
balls move through the air. They are using
that, then, to plan how their hands should
move in order to achieve a successful grasp
of the ball. So we are using our eyes to sense
the ball. We are making a plan and then we are acting, we are moving our hands in order to intercept it.
And the last example is driving, where we
are using our eyes to observe the road, people
and cars that are moving on the road. We’ve
got an idea of where it is we want to go.
So we are using the visual information with
a goal in mind. We are making a plan about
how to navigate down this particular bit of
road and then we are acting by turning the
steering wheel, pushing the brake pedal or
the accelerator.